don't don't worry about the opponent
worry about us and we'll figure it out
so we're underway on the Vegas Strip hope you
enjoy this one tonight an opportunity it is
for the coyotes here to measure their
game again made two spectacular saves
there save awkward into the end boards didn't
look good in front the score coyotes come to
the strip and they take down the defending
Stanley Cup champions now Carone right to
the front he scores that got through shots
Carone to the fridy stars are now gaining
confidence and learning to play the right way
let's see if they can break through against
the Colorado Avalanche Ingram s and one over
his last eight and we are underway at momentet
Arena home stand rolling on C fo to the front SM
scores oh what a set up and a finish and we're
tiing it toes finished that second period out
shooting Colorado 10 to one Marone will chase
this one down against Josh Manson now carcone
with a wrapper outby scores Michael Carone KN
count high a car again across McKinnon scores
oh man he picks the corner it pass over the line
glove save and tipped to the corner by Ingram
and we're going to overtime tonight then good
melli they score they score OT winner
in the desert and Off the Bench come the
coyotes three straight against Cup champions
prior to that they had lost a three straight
but it seems like they're really starting
to put it together is out there now with
Michael carcone he's got the puck in he
stores Michael carcone King drops it buty
scores three C back out High chance side
of the Neto robed by Conor Ingram what a
night what a homee and the coyotes continue
to roll Keller looking around Keller right
through they scar what a pass and coie the
recipient here's C scores Michael Carone two
nothing to the suer scores Jason suer and the
Coyotes W their win streak to five they are
the hottest team in the National Hockey League
second shot out of the season for Conor Ingram